[Music]
welcome back to another episode of the
camera boys well today we got the hot
seat with the hottest question in the
world and even i've seen the hotter
guests lauren's cow everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
everyone sits in this chair yeah don't
shake it around okay it's more high
quality okay guys
don't jiggle i want to try to kill you
don't do that no please no
it doesn't look as cool
we like to start it cold oh there's no
bar and then turn off the heat
we like to start with the least
interesting stuff and then let the
interesting the interesting stuff for
later yeah so people click away in the
very beginning that's what we're trying
to do right it's about engagement all
right so
engagement later okay that's the new
youtube model
in in honor of bart's cold questions all
right i'm going to try to muster up
all right
what is your favorite kind of office
chair
hmm it's really good that's a good bar
it's a really good cold question
yeah i don't i mean i don't really know
like specifically you don't know the
brand i do like office chairs that um
can like drop really quickly yeah they
have to have like like hydraulics yeah
yeah yeah yeah so so if like if they can
come up high
like how high
oh it's like a hydraulic is that fast
enough yeah was it yeah how would you
rank that
actually that's pretty good those are
pretty cool can i try no just stand and
stay in there i gotta say in the chat it
was a safe answer yeah there's alright
really no like office chairs that well
okay let's get right into it so you
obviously just uh starred in a movie
just full of vengeance
yeah on netflix yes yeah what did you
really think about scale of one to ten
yeah
i thought it was [ __ ] awesome
i really did so you know like okay i i
really did like i watched i watched it
and i was like this is [ __ ] good but
we've been getting a lot of [ __ ]
haters
the movie is a [ __ ] party
and there's a bunch up there there's all
good party poopers there's always gonna
be there's always gonna be haters what
could they be hating on yeah people take
it so
they take it too seriously they like
they want like depth
they want like i'm like it's just a
popcorn flick it's like an action movie
you know just action from beginning to
end they're like oh it wasn't like
saving private ryan what they were like
i'm like what the [ __ ] do you want you
know we're just trying to give you
action we're just trying to keep you
entertained but
yeah i i enjoyed the movie and i enjoyed
the process and it was hey to all the
dedicated fans here uh
help us with the party poopers go out
there leave five-star ratings and then
while you're at it make sure you get on
kindergarten noodles on amazon do the
same thing thanks oh my god he's snuck
in a plug look at that
i haven't done it a long time like 80
videos haven't done a lot he's wearing a
kitchen shirt oh thank you i always
support you he does always support do
you have any kendra's gear absolutely i
heard all of it i wore a kitchen jacket
the day that you couldn't come yeah
in memory of you yeah
i
hot seats for lawrence but thank you
these gingers too
hey lawrence um
how many how many films and tv shows
that are like notable have you been in
because like when people are like oh you
know there's an asian guy um [ __ ]
walking dead i'm like yeah he's my
friend and they're like no no no i'm
talking about glenn no not that guy yeah
i know i know but i know the other guy
who was the [ __ ] governor's
homie
that was the right hand man for the
governor and they're like who is that
guy
hey did they do did they do glenn dirty
yeah did they [ __ ] him over did they do
glenn dirty
um i didn't even continue watching so i
don't even know how they did glenn all i
know is they killed him right that's
doing dirty he was supposed to die
earlier
he shouldn't die no but he was supposed
to die earlier
they kept them on longer
he wasn't supposed to die
that late do you guys feel like he was
he was done dirty i didn't watch it
either did you ever did you ever look at
glenn on set and think to yourself like
that should have been me yeah
my
coming god going back decided man i was
just happy to be there i'm like [ __ ]
this is crazy besides the walking dead
what else have you done
um don't tell him about honey four we
gotta get that off are you on honey four
holy [ __ ] you're a honeymoon
[Laughter]
what's your favorite thing you've been
in and why is it the bring your own
balloon party
because bring your own balloon is
[ __ ] awesome
hang on for for like all of us in the
world who don't know what that is can
you maybe backfill that what the [ __ ] is
that dude it's just my favorite sketch
that he's written
so lauren says uh
did something i pitched it to you guys
and you guys are like wait what the [ __ ]
is this remember
yeah so lawrence did a studio 64 comedy
with canals come later today uh they did
use youtube comedy sketches and stuff
like that really just short sketches and
they shot this video called bring your
own balloon
and it still doesn't make sense i don't
know how to explain it but it if you
watch it you'll understand things about
lawrence and you're like i get it
i had to take it down what because i
feel like
racist a little bit
but that's the best kind of agent yeah
oh it's like
it's not it's because the way you're
talking to the girl no it's not that
it's just like what we're wearing and
stuff
the froze yeah i feel like i feel like
that just went in like come on i mean i
think it's hilarious but we're wearing
afros we're wearing afros in the video
oh
but you guys are so racist i [ __ ]
hate you guys
that's right
what honest first impression of joe
[ __ ] crazy come on man you're nuts
when was the first time no we met in
australia
what did i do that was so different in
australia look you're the same you're
the same now yeah
no
come on man you're a wild man
it's not a negative thing it's like man
this guy is
he's on something
he's awesome you're funny
you're [ __ ] funny you see how high
his voice is getting every time he says
it yeah you're funny really yeah yeah
you're great
oh i have a question can i ask it yes
yeah thank you for raising your hand
though i forgot the [ __ ] format all
right there's
there's a there's a youtube uh video
that that lauren's put up before where
it's like um i'll post part two when
this video gets this many likes
and then it looks like it's almost there
it's like been years would you make it
part two if it reached that number um
i want to say no because i don't want to
make this thing
but if it gets there you know what what
is this thing
i don't even know what it is yeah
backfill that too please sorry go ahead
go ahead
and he doesn't know the context neither
do i i don't know i was making these
like um i could i wouldn't even call
them sketches they were just like little
small short film things and then i i
told p the audience like if i get to a
specific the specific amount of views
i'd make another one all right let's
[ __ ] get it there yo
and you totally don't want to make it
but what year was that
but what year was that wasn't that like
ages ago like 12 11 dude oh whoa yeah
and but the numbers are get it's almost
there you know my favorite [ __ ] from you
is when you did jeremy lin [ __ ]
playing oh dude that's legendary he made
a viral um wait that was you yeah
like the paranoia
you're derek fisherman oh my god i can't
believe that was you yeah
holy [ __ ] so context for that one uh
jeremy lin was going crazy during that
once insanity yeah that's the time of my
life
you know i made this video uh under
studio 64 comedy called superior
intellect so you take highlight clips
from jeremy lin and then he would like
freeze frame it and he would like draw
mathematic equations and use his uh
quadratic formula yeah the quadratic
difference
when i look back on it right now i feel
a little bit bad i'm like man this is
like this is this mean no that was the
best i'm like but then i'm like this is
hilarious you're saying he's smart
jeremy lin loved it he's calculated
it was so good it's great dude it was
better than when they they when the new
york times put like [ __ ] in the armor
and then put a picture of jeremy lin
like that was way worse that's pretty
[ __ ] insane terrible that what you
did was [ __ ] hilarious okay out of
everything that you've learned and
experienced in in hollywood right what
is like one of the biggest lessons that
you have for an aspiring actor out there
biggest lesson
um it doesn't matter if it's depressing
too
make it depressing if you can
i mean i i guess it's just to like not
take anything too seriously just to just
uh just to keep going if this is what
you want to do if this just this is your
job then you have to treat it like this
is your job and not think of it as like
something that's so like
something that you can't reach because
like like to try to become a doctor you
still have to like go through you have
to go you have to go to like [ __ ]
medical school and then you gotta do all
this [ __ ] that i don't feel i can do but
if you treat it like it's like
this is your work and you know the
necessary steps to get to where you need
to get to then it won't be as daunting
because i feel like people just put it
on such a high pedestal that they they
feel like oh it's so hard to [ __ ]
achieve but if you think about it like
oh it's just
it's just a [ __ ] normal job it was
really beautifully put can you do it
again but not wiggle the chair so much
this chair is supposed to be like
sturdy
it's a lawn chair
uh no that's great that was a great
answer so as an as an actor like you do
you find um if you're researching for
something do you ever have you ever put
yourself into somebody else's shoes like
actually drop there to try to like
understand them more or
yeah the method are you more like the
type of i could just show up and i just
like to hit my marks and nail the lines
and the intentions
uh no yeah i i feel like i have to try
to understand like i feel like you have
to get your head space in the
you know in the
in the right head space of the character
for sure like i can't just show up and
be like okay i'm gonna say my lines you
know there's not gonna be enough like
depth or meaning into like the delivery
or anything you know it's like all about
building the subconscious of that kind
of character and letting things come out
whenever they come out so it's not
really necessarily memorizing the lines
but it's just like
understanding the character and then
just going on set when they call action
you already have the lines and it's just
like hopefully the things that come out
will be stuff that you've worked on
do you have a specific memory like as a
child that makes you go like oh yeah i
remember that that's why i wanted to act
um it's a good question
i mean
i hate telling the story but this is
like just like it's like that typical it
would
i keep repeating this story a lot but
it's like when i was in high school i
got falsely accused of something i was
trying to be an actor at that time and i
was i had to go i was in jail for
attempted murder and then um well i
don't know this story i just don't want
i just hate talking about it so i'm
talking about so interesting why are you
not giving me the juice bro
i gotta hear about the [ __ ] balloon
video yeah
you should have brought up attempted
murder from the joke ten thousand people
clicked the wave before they got to this
juices this is why we start really cold
why don't we do it to ourselves
i just started acting in high school
and i was it was the opening night of a
play that i was supposed to do and then
i get falsely accused of attempted
murder on the opening night of the show
and i get arrested do they think you're
an asian gang member yes and you look
like someone else they thought they
thought i was someone else but then
murder mystery dinner
no
no no because then you have weapons on
you and you're like oh no no no
dinner theater
but yeah so i spent i was in jail and
then
this is high school this was in high
school and then i was i was in there for
over 72 hours holy [ __ ] 72 hours today's
video is brought to you by dipsy
emails laundry groceries the list goes
on there's a lot on your to-do list but
what should be number one the answer is
you this year put yourself first with
the help of dipsy dipsy stories is an
app full of sexy audio stories and now
they even have brand new written stories
no matter who you're into or what turns
you on dipsy helps bring stories to life
anytime anywhere close your eyes and let
yourself get lost in a world where only
good things happen and where pleasure is
your only priority explore your
fantasies in a safe and shame-free way
there are hundreds of stories to choose
from and they release new content every
week so there's always more to explore
and they also have wellness sessions to
help you wind down and explore and sleep
sessions to help you drift off
for listeners of the show dipsy is
offering an extended 30-day free trial
when you go to dipsystories.com
off the record that's 30 days of full
access for free when you go to
d-i-p-s-e-a-s-t-o-r-i-e-s
dot com slash off the record dipsy
stories dot com slash off the record i
was i was i was okay at first because i
thought oh they're gonna release me i'll
be fine
uh but um after talking to like an
officer he said oh
you're you've been in here for long
enough so i feel like they have enough
evidence on you and i'm like how how
long am i going to be in here and
they're like probably at least 40 years
holy [ __ ] at that point at that age i
was just like it wasn't at least i was
still 17 so it was juvie
it wasn't anything crazy but i turned 18
while while i was in jail
and um you spent your birthday in jail
yeah holy [ __ ] how long were you in drew
before a week oh damn and so
did your inmate friends give you a
birthday yeah what's birthday in jail
birthday was uh open the door happy
birthday close the door oh that's nice
that was pretty nice actually though i
thought they would jump you have a
schizo like like uh cell mate though oh
which was pretty insane because he was
like talking to me we had a good
conversation and all of a sudden he was
just like
who the [ __ ] are you
whoa and then i was just like oh [ __ ] he
forgot he just didn't know who i was
just be like well i'll tell i was
talking to you well i guess i'll tell my
story again yeah this is me but anyways
i was in jail and i really thought i was
gonna stay there for like a long period
of time
and i was freaking out and then i was
thinking about [ __ ] what i want to do
when i get out and i was thinking like i
i love acting and i thought to myself
that that's what i'm gonna do when i
[ __ ] get out of here and luckily
enough i get released
um
you know
five six days later and it was the
closing night of the show
that i was supposed to be in and your
understand's killing it at her yeah yeah
[ __ ] that understudy guy
they replaced you
right name that guy's name by the way
he's glenn on the walking dead
[Laughter]
[ __ ] that guy but then yeah when i was
on stage and i was able to perform i it
was that moment where i told myself yeah
this is what i want to do for the rest
of my life because i was just like [ __ ]
i was about to like
not be able to do that and so why do you
hate that story
because i've been telling it for so long
yeah but not here goddammit our audience
don't [ __ ] know it's a great story i
didn't even know we knew your favorite
office chair before we knew i liked it
better when you ended with we still
don't really i like it better when you
end my saying and i sent it to myself to
a life of acting
he's never said that but all i know
about all i know about this fool is you
don't like to wear underwear that's it
yeah i heard that too
yeah
right now [ __ ] wore underwear today
dad you're growing fool do you wear
underwear wait how falsely accused were
you
about the underwear thing no i was
living with him no
underwear i i actually don't a lot
don't i don't know i like it i like just
i like it to be just there's more air
there's less things on i don't wear
underwear when i wear shorts it's like
when you guys sleep sometimes you guys
just want to sleep like with nothing on
yeah you're wearing shorts right now
wait did they have underwear did they
ever catch the real guy
no
what the [ __ ]
um there was just not enough evidence it
wasn't it wasn't just me it was probably
me and other people
no no i didn't do it
but there was a group there was a group
of people that got caught up
your high school friends too yes yes
damn and there was like there were some
people that were still in jail for like
three months oh [ __ ]
they didn't do [ __ ] and they had to like
sell their homes oh my god money to like
bail the guy out it was bad i actually
got sued in college i got served papers
because i i guess the people that um
that got severely messed up were like
yeah you guys caused trauma in my life
or like what you like yeah like a civil
suit later why why you because he was a
kid that was cause that was part of that
well how would they sue you if you
didn't do [ __ ]
that's correct
i guess they see it everywhere america
civil yeah wow oh my god what a [ __ ]
mess bro and the police like that that
handled the whole situation they were
just so [ __ ] up man it's like i was in
a cell and um
some um some kid needed a to use a
restroom and they wouldn't let him so he
had to pee on the floor and they made
him take off his clothes and like wipe
up his own piss whoa i saw an officer
just like choke somebody
it's pretty nuts
goddamn it we're in the show
like just straight up jokes i'm choking
kid i'm like what the [ __ ] is going on
it was
pretty intense yeah cops are pretty
[ __ ] up yep yeah they're pretty bad so
so fast forward now that uh you went
through that traumatic traumatic
experience and then you're like you
ascended to your acting career after
that you know it was crazy
go so so to do to do woo assassins i had
to get through the canadian border right
oh and when i was going through the
canadian border
they said oh what is this thing on your
record we're not letting you in you
can't you can't do this you can't work
you had a record oh because you're 18.
it whole between u.s and canada it holds
a long time they didn't expunge it
so then i was a juvenile [ __ ] my
pants because i was like man the thing
that that made me want to do this in the
first place was now preventing me from
like
like doing what i would love to do and
then i was like [ __ ] you have to tell
that whole story at the border is that
why you don't like
maybe so many times yeah all the
canadian officials
did you start with it's not what it
looks like don't worry i was accused of
attempted murder
it wasn't me though
but i've been acquitted of all charges
i'm acquittable of our all charges they
say they were gonna call they they were
gonna call
uh a court in la
and if if no one picked up and explained
what was going on they wouldn't let me
through the border holy [ __ ] and so i
was just chilling there [ __ ] in my pants
thinking like well i guess i'm not gonna
[ __ ] work anymore did they make you
wipe the [ __ ] with your own clothes
so then they called and then think
wonder if that's why
we we sort of got stopped too in
australia if that's why and you put me
through that i'm gonna sue you
we already determined it was victor's
fault
yeah so somebody picked up and then what
happened
they called someone picked up and then
uh
[ __ ] luckily and uh you're like it's
expunged yeah it's expunged and so i had
to so now i have to carry this piece of
paper i went back to the courts to get
like to get it all taken care of so that
whenever i'm traveling i need like this
piece of paper with me
to show that it's it's been expunged
yeah i had to go to the
to the court to it's like a bait did you
go downtown l.a yeah or it's at the
basement right and then you have to ask
the desk wait don't [ __ ] gloss why
the [ __ ] do you have to go to court oh i
have some
i had some i have juvenile records
oh just nothing like
just like murder not like like graffiti
and like theft and like so art like yeah
like graffiti art yeah
yeah like whatever we have we have a lot
of actors come on to the show we always
want to get to like the nitty-gritty and
really ask like the serious questions
that really define people's characters
so like um if you were like casting a
movie and then you were cast with a a
co-star that you could just have a
beautiful beautiful sex scene with who
would be
who would you [ __ ] that [ __ ] out of dude
who would you [ __ ] get flesh-colored
underwear over your pants and just grind
on
it's okay everybody everybody it's just
flattery you know whoever you say unless
it's awkward and you've already worked
with them and i'd say like 90 percent of
all
act act actors right now
that's who you would [ __ ] take 90
percent yeah he's saying everyone's hot
except for britney spears apparently
this [ __ ] guy i swear to god she's
gross
[Laughter]
britney spears it is
then we'll never fight against the same
oh ladies well
really that's right i'm dating sorry
like i don't know i'm just trying to
think like
you don't have a celebrity crush in the
acting who makes
know what makes you horny i don't have a
celebrity card i have i i've had
celebrity crushes when i was younger
okay tell me that shannon saw semen oh
yeah she's great who's that
who's that there's a short hair like
he's been forty nights girl oh yeah okay
yeah
we've reached the 20 minute and 12
second part of the show this is the part
of the show we're like turn the heat so
can i ask do you have any regrets
regrets rag rats uh yeah yeah yeah i i
do i think i have
he's just like killing that guy
[Laughter]
i killed him i killed a
oh
man
[Laughter]
editor don't cut that out
please don't leave it
anywhere
i think i regret like when i got away
with murder that would be so shocking
then they use this video and [ __ ] put
them back in
imagine
no i don't want to no
falsely accused twice because jk news
yeah they reopened the case they're like
well there was that jk video
it was on a legitimate news
let's take another look
joe's the witness they bring in he's
like yeah i mean he said it
he was on the hot seat
man i always lie for you lawrence
nobody lies over here he didn't do it he
didn't know anybody y'all
lord did not commit any crimes
okay
back to the regret um i think i think i
would go back and like try to enjoy um
like all the america's dance crew stuff
that happened afterwards i think i
always talk about this like i don't
think i was really present in that
moment in time i was just trying to like
not dance anymore
at that time and i feel like if i could
go back in time just to enjoy all the
travels and be like yeah this is [ __ ]
dope this is great wait you were you
were on abdc he was on top of modern
season one oh what
and they [ __ ]
like that was that was what 2008 2008
right
so how did you not enjoy it though they
actually got beat by jabbawockeez you
was trying to act more i was trying to
act more and then and then i just
graduated college and then um
you know i wanted to immediately start
to like you know like
auditioning for things and just start my
career but then dance was just the only
thing that was paying me a lot of money
and then so we we would just travel all
the time and i felt like it was taking
away from
what i what i just really wanted i
remember you you said that too back then
and i was like what but you guys are
doing everything i know that's crazy and
then just like doing like uh meet and
greets and stuff i was like oh
but it but if i could go back in time i
would just
try to be present and enjoy
you know that but if you're killing that
acting you'd be immediately still
[ __ ] traveling and doing stuff you
know
you should have thought about that
nobody's wanted it's like getting a
[ __ ] when you wanted to get your dick
ridden
that's exactly what it's like exactly
it's pretty nice but still like but what
do you want it though way better than
getting your dick right
yeah i think it's just like what your
heart desires is what your heart desires
the cool thing is i remember when when
you guys are traveling a ton and like
they they pretty much like pave the way
for like
the crews after to do the same types of
tours because we really just did the
same places they did because after they
toured all of those venues and those
companies believed that oh dance crews
are a good thing to hire for these
things now so it was like a proven model
they really did pave like the way for
that [ __ ] and i remember talking to you
when i was in costa mesa living there
and you were like man i'm trying to do
more acting and stuff yeah i was like
dude i would love to do what you're
doing no like i hate myself like i want
to punch myself in the face because like
i was just like
hey but australia was fun though and if
it wasn't for that we would and them all
met australia was [ __ ] fun right yeah
that was really cool take the tour too
there it is again we should do a tick
tick tour without poriotic
he points points to the foot because
chad's in there
have him come and record us
oh my god
i thought the [ __ ] path can record
you guys but then he can do his hand
things in front of the camera like that
that's really good i know right
i watch him i want it
[Music]
[Music]